zusammen herzlich willkommen zur zdf
heute live auf ihrem live stream zu
aktuellen ereignissen und diskussionen
eigentlich will die katholische kirche
ja die serien ihrer gläubigen retten
aber die gläubigen zumindest viele von
denen fragen sich mittlerweile ob sie
nicht ihre kirche retten müssen
beziehungsweise ob es dafür nicht
vielleicht sogar schon ein bisschen zu
spät ist
die missbrauchsskandale der vergangenen
jahrzehnte die haben der katholischen
kirche ganz schön zugesetzt waren für
viele katholiken der letzte grund dann
doch mal auszutreten
aber es gibt noch sehr viel mehr gründe
und entsprechend noch mehr forderungen
was sich in der katholischen kirche doch
bitte jetzt mal endlich ändern sollte im
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert heute hat
sich die deutsche bischofskonferenz zu
ihrem traditionellen frühjahrstreffen
gemeinsam zusammengeschaltet muss man
sagen corona konformen war das ganze
digital und manche dachten das wäre es
schon an neuerungen 2021 in der
katholischen kirche aber tatsächlich gab
es noch eine neue eine überraschung die
kammer hat nachmittag denn die
bischofskonferenz hat eine frau zu ihrer
neuen generalsekretärin ernannt beate
gilles soll ab jetzt quasi für die
bischofskonferenz die amtsgeschäfte
führen
da fahre ich doch gleich mal der beiden
gäste heute im stream ob das ganze jetzt
die überraschung und die neuerung ist
mit der selbst geschrieben sind ich
begrüße machen die am meisten von der
leyen organisation maria 2.0 und carolin
kebekus ihres zeichens satire karin und
ja in diesen beruf quasi schon jetzt
katholische berufs kritikerin zumindest
häufig aufgefallen mit ziemlich
kritischen äußerungen ist das jetzt die
neuerungen auf die sie gewartet haben
können sie sich zufrieden zurück liegt
es gibt die man die runde
2000 jahre war ja zeit wir freuen uns
natürlich dass jetzt eine frau im
nietzsche als generalsekretärin der
deutschen bischofskonferenz eingesetzt
worden ist aber die forderung nach
frauen sind ja schon viel viel länger
und es wäre es ist einfach überall
gewesen
das ist eine frau letztendlich wird aber
ist ja nur ein erster anfang
das heißt das reicht ihnen so noch nicht
3 natürlich nicht ändert ja nichts an
der strukturellen diskriminierung der
frauen
klebe kurs sie predigen ja schon lange
die gier die katholische kirche an oder
prangern sie an könnte man sagen unter
anderem mit zeilen wie das muss ich
jetzt wirklich zitieren lasst uns rein
entschuldigung in euren pimmel verein
kann entscheide sünde sein wenn sie
sagen ihre arbeit hat den weg dafür frei
gemacht
ob das meine arbeit war weiß ich nicht
aber ich glaube es ist es ist einfach an
der zeit es ist die bewegung auch mit
den kolleginnen schon war ja 2.0 und ja
der sich ja auch wahnsinnig viele
gläubige verbunden fühlen das ist
einfach eine überreife situation also
das musste ein passieren dass es auch
nichts was die katholische kirche
aussitzen kann was man sagen kann das
ist jetzt eine erscheinung
das ist eine modeerscheinung sondern ich
glaube das lässt sich nicht mehr
aufhalten
es ist ein fakt also entweder die kirche
nutzt jetzt diese engagierten frauen
oder sie geht unter wir hören mal an was
sie als engagierte frau beruflich der
kirche mitgegeben haben letztes jahr in
folgendem werk hier
die männer am altar frauen kannst du
ewig suchen ist weitaus mehr vierteilen
käsekuchen der priester bei
herkömmlicher hat jemand mit einer
scheibe wir haben euch gewaschen musste
die umsatz
wer das sagen wer gewinnt gegenwärtig
kollegen den gewinn um zu beten
wegen schwester ihr vermisstes wissen
doch auch in der schweiz abflüge bis du
uns gibt keine hoffnung nicht
wie das klappen können frauen davon
mit bussen warteten
[Musik]
ja
med
tja also deutliche und ziemlich deftige
worte frau klebe kurs war es gab es denn
da an die resonanz aus der katholischen
bild also von der bischofskonferenz gab
es tatsächlich eine reaktion die aber so
ein bisschen lahm war weil da wurde
überhaupt nicht auf die kritik
eingegangen sondern ich hätte hingegen
irgendwas verstoßen gegen das hatte ich
aber gar nicht verstoßen also ich habe
da niemanden beleidigt und das war
schade eigentlich weil ich habe
ansonsten von sehr vielen auch von
vielen leuten aus der kirche also von
pfarrer natürlich dann nicht offiziell
habe ich da total viel zustimmung
bekommen und ich glaube dass die der
wille nach diesen reformen auch bei ganz
vielen da ist aber bei denen die was
verändern könnten nicht aber letzten
endes sind sie aus der kirche
ausgetreten wieso ich bin ausgetreten
vor acht oder sieben jahren und zwar mit
einer totalen gut im bauch damals ich
war gar nicht anders möglich für mich
ich bin wirklich wütend zum amtsgericht
gegangen in köln damals konnte man noch
am automaten austreten heute sind die
auftrittstermine ja schwierig hier
schläger zu bekommen als impftermine
damals war ich einfach wahnsinnig bieten
es kamen so viele dinge zusammen
in köln wurde war der fall bekannt von
einer jungen frau die vergewaltigt wurde
und in keinem katholischen krankenhaus
einen nachsorge termin bekommen hat weil
sie die pille danach nicht kam
eine kindergärtnerin aus dem
bekanntenkreis hat ihren job verloren
weil die wieder geheiratet hat bei einem
kindergarten dessen träger die
katholische kirche war
ich hatte einfach ein ein langes leben
hinter mir das in dem ich sehr verbunden
war der kirche auch meine eltern waren
sehr engagiert in der kirche und in dem
ich irgendwann gemerkt habe ich bin
gläubiger zweiter klasse und nicht nur
ich sondern auch mal also nicht nur mein
leben
auch das meiner freundin meiner
homosexuellen freunde war nicht
anerkannt und ja ich habe mich ich hab'
ich war dann einfach so wütend und dann
natürlich der missbrauchsskandal diese
ganzen fälle die aufkamen und wie diese
wie mit diesen menschen umgegangen wird
mit den opfern umgegangen wird bis heute
das hat mich wahnsinnig gemacht und ich
konnte damals nicht anders reagieren und
ich bewundere jeden auch gerade die
kolleginnen schon maria 2 uhr die in der
kirche bleiben und sagen nein wir haben
die energie und wollen quasi von innen
eine veränderung schaffen aber damals
ich war einfach nur ein bisschen wut
merkt man glaube ich jetzt auch noch
wenn sie das so erzählen wenn wir uns
mal die zahl der kirchenaustritte
anschauen dann stellen wir auch fest
dass sie damit nicht alleine sind mit
ihrem entschluss auszutreten
tausende wollten in köln zuletzt einen
termin zum austritt aus der katholischen
kirche
doch die server des amtsgerichts der
domstadt gegen vergangene woche
schlichtweg in die knie es waren zu
viele die zur gleichen zeit einfach nur
noch eines wollten raus aus der
glaubensgemeinschaft ein trend der nicht
gänzlich neu ist schon 2010 gab es nach
missbrauchsfällen eine austrittswelle
mehr als 180.000 mitglieder verlor die
katholische kirche damals zwar flachte
die kurve dann ab doch der nächste
höhepunkt ließ nicht lange auf sich
warten
2014 kehrten mehr als 200 17.000
menschen der kirche den rücken zu und
zuletzt stiegen die zahlen sogar wieder
2009 10 lag die zahl der
kirchenaustritte bei mehr als 270.000
ein neuer rekord so wir haben wir hier
auch in die köpfe rein gefragt wie
haltet ihr es mit der religion also die
gerät in frage gestellt und tatsächlich
gibt es dir das feedback von nico zum
beispiel der meinte ich werde so schnell
wie möglich austreten
ich meinte die kirche ist auch einfach
ne sekte ich bin schon lange ausgetreten
und stefan kopp hat das bisschen
bestätigt was rohkost gesagt hat er
meine schwester sich scheiden lassen
würde wäre sie ihren job los
aber frau kebekus wenn jetzt alle ihren
mitgliedsausweis zurück geben und das
kruzifix von der wand hängen dann
bleiben nur noch die übrig die nichts
verändern wollen
also wie gesagt das ist ja etwas was
mich auch total irritiert also ich was
mich an der ganzen sache wirklich
fassungslos dastehen lässt ist da sind
menschen und davon auch viele frauen die
wollen die kirche verändern und die
lieben diese kirche die stehen da mit
vollem engagement die sie stehen damit
in ihrer energie und man sagt den
einfach ab und zwar weil weil warum also
warum wollen woher kommt diese angst
privilegien abzugeben an frauen
abzugeben
und dass das ist etwas das kann ich das
aber ist vielleicht das schon
privilegien abgeben ist ja per se
einfach mal unbequem war hat man sie
naja aber aber ansonsten geht ja also
dann ist ja die firma pleite
also ich meine das ist die diese diese
engagierten frauen sind doch die letzte
rettung für die kirche in deutschland
doch ich hab das gefühl man macht lieber
zu als dass man die frauen reinlässt
einer von ihnen sehen wir neben ihnen
maria messi an von maria 2.0 sie sind in
der kirche geblieben promis wie an
obwohl sie glaube ich ähnliche
kritikpunkte habe wie rocky bewusst
wieso ich habe dann gleich und
kritikpunkte natürlich weil die kluft
zwischen dem was wir in der christlichen
botschaft 10 und dem was die kirche lebt
die es inzwischen fast unüberbrückbar
geworden und ich kann auch wirklich
jeden verstehen der sich dieser
körperschaft des öffentlichen rechts ab
wird aber ich glaube keinem kann man ja
dann sagen dass er vom glauben
abgefallen ist insofern mache ich
inzwischen gefasst keinen unterschied
mehr zwischen denen die wirklich bleiben
aber aufstehen und etwas verändern
möchten
und eben die eben aus gewissensgründen
auch jetzt diese kirche verlassen also
ich kann ich kann das verstehen und ich
glaube man kann diese kirche von innen
und von außen verändern ich zehnmal so
ein bisschen auf was maria 2.0 fordert
das sind insgesamt sieben thesen komme
gleich nochmal dezidiert darauf aber
darin steht sie wollen ämter auf für
alle also auch für die frauen ins
priester an demokratische
machtverteilung aufklärung von
missbrauchsvorwürfen und dass die
verantwortlichen zur rechenschaft
gezogen werden
wertschätzung von allen arten von
partnerschaften ein ende der zölibat
pflicht und weniger prunk und keine
persönliche bereicherung mehr an
kircheneigentum sind das jetzt
forderungen die zu radikal und
revolutionär sind weil das doch jetzt
quasi die grundfesten der kirche der
katholischen kirche angreift oder haben
sie das gefühl sorry ist es 2021 wir
sind ungefähr 100 jahres gespielt
genauso radikal wie unser religions-
also wie jesus eigentlich war und so
revolutionär nur hat die kirche
irgendwie ein salto rückwärts gemacht
und in 2000 jahren in macht system
etabliert des menschen schädigt und das
nicht gerecht ist und das ist eigentlich
das problem unsere forderungen sind
eigentlich finde ich gar nicht so
revolutionär also die kirche wenn sie
das tun würde würde sie sich wieder der
christlichen botschaft annähern
sie haben aber jetzt am sonntag mit
mehreren mitstreiterinnen ihre thesen an
mehrere kirchentüren in deutschland
genagelt sie wissen schon was das jetzt
einmal passiert ist also dass jemand
gemacht hat die diskurs mit denen die
angeblich wissen was wirklich katholisch
ist führen die werden autoritär geführt
und da wird gesagt vor 30 jahren wurde
das so entschieden und jetzt sind die
frauen einfach nicht mehr am drücker die
nächsten 2000 jahre und das ist
natürlich radstall ist sicher keine frau
des 21 jahrhunderts eigentlich mehr
darauf ein auch das theologische niveau
ist ja da unterirdisch wenn ich immer so
reingucken gibt's ja auch ein kommentar
von handwerkerin mit jurik das ist
wieder so hetze gegen die kirche
schreibt sie die katholische kirche hat
auch wahnsinnig viele positive aspekt
das ist doch einfach nur noch peinlich
wie agnostisch deutschland geworden ist
okay wenn sie nicht das gefühl dass sie
mit ihrer doch sehr deftigen kritik dann
auch vielleicht solche vorurteile gegen
die katholische kirche weiter
untermauern und dafür sorgen dass da
überhaupt niemand mehr hin möchte gerade
nicht unter 50
das glaube ich nicht ich glaube dass es
eher leute dazu animiert sich der
reformation an zu schießen und
erschweren die angaben das wissen sie
das sind die anderen die reformierten
das war der andere verein ein die die
reform wollen die meine ich dass ich
glaube eher dass es leute dazu animiert
also das was ich mache
zu sagen naja stimmt da muss sich was
ändern also dass es einfach mehr leute
gibt die die frauen fordern also ich
glaube nicht dass das so dass ich das im
gegenteil beitrage wer heute katholische
kirche sagt der muss leider ja auch
immer noch missbrauchsvorwürfe sagen und
er zu wenig aufklärung auch seit jahren
verspricht die kirche das aufzuklären
und dahinter zu steigen schon elf jahre
ist es her dass da die große erste welle
durch die katholische kirche ging das
klappt nach je nach bist du mal mehr und
mal weniger gut und der zeit hat aber
das bistum köln da ein wirklich
mittelschweres bis ziemlich schweres
problem wegen seines vorgehens wenden
sich immer mehr gläubige ab rainer maria
woelki der kölner kardinal kämpft
derzeit mit einem
glaubwürdigkeitsproblem
denn er hatte entschieden ein gutachten
zur aufarbeitung sexualität gewalt unter
verschluss zu halten
für die einen ein skandal für ihn ein
normaler vorgang der geistliche verweist
auf methodische mängel und auf ein neues
gutachten das soll am 18 märz auf den
tisch kommen doch der druck wächst schon
am wochenende wandte sich woelki an die
öffentlichkeit er gestand fehler bei der
aufarbeitung von missbrauchs vergehen
ein und in seiner krisenkommunikation
wenn die kirche der versuchung erliegt
den eigenen ruf zu schützen und
missbrauch vertuscht
dann setzt sie ihre macht für sich
selbst ein
dieser versuchung gilt es zu widerstehen
die gleichen vorwürfe hatte das duo für
ihre nachfolge von tschuldigung wollen
wir gerade zugehört was das problem der
katholischen kirche in köln ist wir
wollten auch gerne mit einem vertreter
der katholischen kirche in köln sprechen
oder mit einem vertreter der
bischofskonferenz
leider hat aber jemand für uns heute
abend zeit gehabt das ist das
hauptargument von herrn wilkie warum
dieses erste gutachten nicht
veröffentlicht ist wir können das so
nicht veröffentlichen weil täter so
eventuell identifizierbar sind und ist
mit tusche schwenninger gebe sie stehen
ja selbst in der öffentlichkeit sie
wissen was passieren kann wenn sehr hoch
mal geschädigt ist jetzt haben sie
verständnis dass wir das dieses
gutachten deswegen macht veröffentlicht
wird nein weil damit schützt man ja
schon wieder täter und ich glaube wenn
ich es richtig verstanden habe die
kanzlei tigges gutachten gemacht hat die
sagt ja da gibt es keine methodischen
mängeln das ist alles einwandfrei ich
glaube eher dass es dass es ein anderes
problem noch gibt neben dem dass man die
täter natürlich mich so benennen möchte
was ja aber zwingend ist für so eine
aufarbeitung wenn man die glaubwürdig
machen möchte aber ich glaube dass auch
die ganzen gutachten nicht nur im
erzbistum köln ja auch eine etwas dem
zugrunde liege eine art begründung
finden wollen und ich glaube das ist
etwas was man auch nicht hören will
nämlich dass die strukturen der kirche
einfach diesen strukturellen missbrauch
begünstigen und ich glaube das ist etwas
was man lieber nicht hören will und ich
kann weiß nicht was jetzt am 18 märz ist
der da das datum wann das andere
gutachten veröffentlicht werden soll
was dann passiert ich meine es ist ja
nicht nur in köln sondern auch ich
glaube in anderen erzbistümern war so
das geschwärzte seiten veröffentlicht
wurden wo man denkt ja gut wofür hat man
diese gutachten gemacht und wann kommt
denn da wirklich mal die
staatsanwaltschaft und das problem ist
natürlich aber schon dass einige der
beschuldigten halt nicht mehr am leben
sind sich nicht mehr wehren können und
von da her da auch im zweifel für den
angeklagten gerichtet werden muss also
das ist ja so mit 1 der juristischen
begründungen
es gibt aber auch in der katholischen
kirche sehr verschiedene meinungen dazu
zum vorgehen von
herrenberg ii der von der
bischofskonferenz georg bätzing der hat
dazu folgendes gesagt ich glaube
kardinal welt dass sein aufklärungswille
wirklich deutlich und klar ist die
unruhe die entstanden ist insofern die
erste die erste das erste gutachten
zurückgehalten wird die ist mir aber
genauso verständlich und sie treibt mich
auch der kardinal hat gerade am
wochenende in einem hirtenwort noch
einmal deutlich gemacht worum es dabei
geht
ich habe mehrfach mit dem kardinal
gesprochen ich habe ihm auch die
alternative genannt
die darin bestünde das gutachten das
erste gutachten zu veröffentlichen und
öffentlich darüber diskutieren zu lassen
ob es rechtsfähig gerichts fähig und das
ist ja sein anliegen gerecht ist
der kardinal hat seine entscheidung
getroffen und ich glaube wir werden
jetzt warten müssen bis zum 18
märz kommission von maria 2.0 sind sie
ziehen bätzing oder team will keines von
beiden also für mich ist das für mich
das schlimmste ist eigentlich dass in
der ganzen zeit von den verantwortlichen
amtsträger die vertuscht haben kein
einziges wort der entschuldigung über
die lippen gekommen ist und damit meine
ich nicht kardinal wirken
das finde ich erschreckend sondern wie
man sie konkret keine das ist in köln
bekannt keine moralische
verantwortungsübernahme hat stark wie
wir wissen wer zu dieser zeit
generalvikar wir wissen dass alles und
letztlich sind wir kein sportverein
sondern bis in die katholische kirche
und da muss einfach klartext gesprochen
werden und was noch dazu kommt für mich
ist der aufklärungswille nicht wirklich
sichtbar weil dazu würde gehören dass
man einen kirchenbild dass man hat das
in köln sehr konservativ sehr reaktionär
und sehr hierarchisch geprägt ist dass
man das hinterfragt wenn man wirklich an
die ursachen des missbrauchs und dessen
vertuschung an will dann muss man sein
kirchenbild hinterfragen und das ist ihm
ganz anders also wenn man das wirklich
verändern möchte und das ist
wird hier am sollen sind gemerkt kein
anderes päischen bildzeilen als am 18
wenn wir jetzt mal gucken in die
kommentare da stelle ich fest dass da
doch sich viele ihren kritikpunkten
anschließend ich nehme hier exemplarisch
manfred sohns auf facebook gemeint ein
trauerspiel chance um chance wird
verspielt oder darüber claudia fischer
als frau bin ich in der katholischen
kirche ein mensch zweiter klasse ein
paar zentimeter die vorne herabhängen
entscheiden darüber ob ich priester
werden graf oder nur kuchen backe und
die kirche reinige dafür braucht und
sich weiter austreten sobald es geht mir
reicht's ist ich war lange jahre lang
engagiert doch ich kann das mit meinem
gewissen nicht mehr vereinbaren diesem
verein dann anzugehören
da sehe ich jetzt strahlende gesichter
hin beiden aber trotzdem ist es ja im
grunde ein trauerspiel wenn man sowas
feststellen muss der svk können sie sich
erklären dass es so viele vorwürfe gibt
von von jahrelangem missbrauch von so
vielen stimmen und dass da einfach die
ohren verschlossen werden wenn sie das
so sie nämlich dass zumindest klar dass
man es geschafft hat
ja ich glaube da wird sich festgehalten
an alten strukturen das war schon immer
so das hat schon immer so funktioniert
und dann das sind diese männerbünde die
dann zusammen halten und da wird nicht
daran gerüttelt
ich hab im interview gelesen mit dieser
kanzlei die dieses gutachten gemacht hat
in köln
und was mich total beeindruckt hat war
das der anwalt gesagt hat er hat mit
ganz vielen klerikern auch gesprochen
die pünktlich was verändern wollen und
hat denen so angefühlt dass die so
einsam sind und das hat mir das ist mir
so in erinnerung geblieben also ich
glaube da gibt es leute die was
verändern wollen auch und wie wie das
für die auch gerade sein muss die dann
da mittendrin sind und sich denken ich
will aber ich will aber die aufklärung
ich lebe hier für eine andere kirche
also sorry deren möglich ich muss mal
kurz hier einen frauenfeindlichen
kommentar löschen weil sowas drücken wir
hier nichts also in dem sehr gerne
anregungen und fragen hiermit von euch
auf aber wenn es frauenfeindlich wird
dann sehen wir mal
los ich habe aber auch hier einen
kritischen kommentaren habe ich auch
erst aus theologischen kreisen immer
wieder gehört dieses argument
jesus hat die zwölf apostel beauftragt
durch die kirche sein werk vorzuführen
er hat zwölf männer dazu geweiht
ich sehe schon sie wissen was jetzt
kommt und eben keine frau warum stellt
ihr euch gegen das was im evangelium
steht sehr offenen umgang mit frauen
gelegt und dieses argument auch das will
ich eigentlich gar nicht mehr eingehen
weil es theologisch auch nicht wirklich
haltbar ist es war die zwölf waren
sinnbild für die zwölf stämme israels
und jesus hat du mal vor 2000 jahren
gelebt und ich denke es geht hier um
gerechtigkeit und wenn wir das
evangelium anschauen dann ist sie das
zentrum die gerechtigkeit und die muss
sich verwirklichen
darin dass frauen und männer dieselben
rechte haben und warum sollte das rad
eine weniger gültige berufung vom
seelsorgeamt haben als ein mann
dafür gibt es für mich gibt es da keine
antwort darauf keine schlüssige
intelligente ich würde jetzt mal einfach
versuchen eine zu finden
dogmen kirchen religionen brauchen
dogmen das ist ein dogma und das an dem
halten sich kirchen und religionen fest
und das sollte man nicht ändern dass es
zumindest das gefühl was ich immer habe
wenn ich den verteidigern dieser
sichtweise zu nennen
und wenn man sich an sowas festhält dann
wird mir dogmatisch und eng und dann
verbaut man sich eigentlich die zukunft
deshalb müssen auch dogmen immer
hinterfragt war bleiben letztendlich
weil wem nützt ein doch mal wenn danach
sie wollen außerdem den klerus
entmachten ich zitiere aus ihren thesen
der klerikalismus es heute eines der
grundprobleme der katholischen kirche
und fördert den mast machtmissbrauch mit
all seinen menschenunwürdigen facetten
das ist ein ist was man relativ
abstrakter satz
was meinen sie damit konkret ja das was
auch von kebekus stunden gesagt hat es
sind diese männerbünde und dieses
überhöhtes priesterbild ich kenne sehr
viele priester die wirklich
hervorragende seelsorger sind die gute
arbeit machen aber die selbst
überfordert sind teilweise mit dem was
da von einem priester verlangt wird dann
durch die beine ganz besondere andere
sein skript qualität es ist jetzt geht
es theologisch sehr tief erhält und ich
glaube seelsorger müssen menschen sein
die anderen gut zuhören und die ihre ja
ihre gaben an den menschen verwirklichen
können und nicht in irgendwelchen männer
wirken sich an dokument festgehalten
dass muss lebendig bleiben und ich
glaube wenn frauen das priester amt
anstreben dann sage ich immer wir müssen
aber gucken wie wir das viel weiter
denken können das ist wichtig weil der
klerikalismus hat und sehr dahin geführt
wo wir jetzt stehen was heißt dann
weiter lesen ja dass das wäre was ist
wenn die krankenhausseelsorgerin im
krankenhaus sich um die sterbenden
kümmert und da wünscht jemand zum
beispiel das sakrament der
krankensalbung da muss er natürlich
geben dürfen dass es vollkommen absurd
dass dann priester geholt werden muss
dazu also einfach von dem was wir was
braucht der mensch und von dem her
denken das sakrament da er denke nicht
was das muss ja für den menschen da sein
und nicht als selbstzweck
ich habe zwei fragen aus unserer
zuschauerschaft an frau kebekus einmal
von tomtom go auf youtube.de von
johannes prehm sorry die wollte ich
vorlesen was die kann man sich einsetzen
oder was kann man einsetzen ohne dass
gleich so radikal zu sein also das
scheint es schon das gefühl zu geben
dass diese forderung zu radikal sind
ich glaube dass man sich dass man sich
engagieren kann dass man gespräche
nutzen kann dass man verbündete suchen
kann
und ich glaube wenn man mit den leuten
ins gespräch kommt und versucht wo kann
ich was ändern wo kann ich meine meine
forderung an bringen und man kann sich
bestimmt auch mal zwei punkte
anschließen
eine frage dann von jan hufenbach auch
noch auf youtube
denkst du also frauke bewusst wenn
frauen mehr recht in der katholischen
kirche hätten würden auch wieder mehr
junge menschen in die kirche gehen und
sich engagieren
ja ich glaube dass auf jeden fall also
ich glaube wenn die kirche da offener
ist und auch lebensnah und
mehr eben wieder genau messen gesagt
dass im sinne von jesus die kirche
angeht und diese diese thesen verbreitet
dann fühlt sich fühlen sich ja auch die
menschen angesprochen
dann fühlt man sich da auch wieder zu
hause und nicht nicht bestraft dafür wie
man lebt die war eine frage noch an sie
ob sie das wenn sie das jetzt meine
kirche gewesen sind gehen sie das noch
in die kirche oder meiden sie jetzt
quasi diese ganze institution
nein ich gehe ab und zu in die kirche
ich bin auch hochzeiten eingeladen auch
taufen
also ich bin ja auch noch nie
ausgeschlossen worden weil man weil man
sie nicht erkannt hat oder oder weil ich
bekannt war dass sie nicht eigentlich
nicht mehr dazugehören
doch dort man erkennt mich schon aber
ich habe nicht das gefühl dass mir
verboten wird in die kirche zu gehen nur
weil ich aus der kirche ausgetreten bin
ich fühle mich ja trotzdem noch als
getaufte katholiken man kann mir ja
meine erziehung und mein leben in dieser
gemeinde nicht absprechen in dem sinn
und ich habe ja nur der institution
sozusagen meinen rücken gekehrt
wie lange geben sie der kirche noch der
katholischen kirche bevor es zu spät ist
schöne befragung für mich ist noch ein
punkt sehr sehr wichtig was wir machen
ist auch ein politischer kampf also wenn
eine kirche so ein schlechtes frauenbild
verbreitet dann wirkt sie ja in
deutschland lassen sich die frauen das
vielleicht nicht gefallen aber wir haben
wir sind weltweit vernetzt und wir sehen
gesellschaften wo die kirche massiven
großen einfluss noch hat und deshalb
steht eigentlich die kirche warum hinzu
da so hinter erste steht eigentlich in
der pflicht dafür ein ganz anderes
frauenbild zu stehen und deshalb kämpfen
wir darum es geht ihm sitzt eigentlich
in erster linie gar nicht darum dass man
diese macht und rechte und dieses ist es
geht tatsächlich auch um die
menschlichkeit es geht um den wahren
feminismus in dem männer und frauen sich
als menschen begegnen und nicht dieses
herabwürdigende diskriminierungs
geschehen bei das argument wird ja
häufig umgedreht und es wird gesagt der
rest der welt ist
einfach noch nicht so weit wir sind eine
weltkirche also müssen wir uns gemeinsam
bewegen und im grunde wird er das ja
dazu führen dass es eine kirche der zwei
geschwindigkeiten gibt das heißt im
einen kontinent können frauen die
priesterweihe empfangen anderen geht es
noch nicht weil da ist die
gleichberechtigung der frau wirklich
noch jahrzehnte hinter uns das ist ein
ganz ganz oft gehörtes argument und es
stimmt einfach nicht damit unterstützt
die katholische kirche in diesen ländern
einfach nie so grüne und ein
frauenfeindliches systeme und da müsste
sie aufgrund ihrer botschaft ganz anders
agieren frau kebekus wenn jetzt diese
punkte von maria 2.9 erfüllt wären oder
würden würden sie wieder eintreten dass
das waren kurz und knapp ich bedanke
mich bei ihren beiden für für ihre zeit
und für ihre antworten oder abend ich
sie hier in der zuschauerschaft ein paar
kritische stimmen aber sehr viel
zuspruch und ich bin gespannt was sich
daraus entwickelt vielen dank so wie
gesagt wir hätten auch gerne mit einem
vertreter der katholischen kirche
gesprochen aber leider haben wir
niemanden dazu bekommen deswegen habe
ich noch an meinen kollegen jürgen
erbacher aus unserer kirchen redaktion
dazu gebeten damit ja und das ganze noch
ein bisschen einordnet weil nicht jeder
verfolgt die ereignisse in der
katholischen kirche so intensiv wie mein
kollege herr erbacher wenn sie erst
diese forderungen hören von maria 2.0
sind das radikale splittergruppen ideen
oder ist es tatsächlich schon fast im
mainstream
das ist glaube ich kann man schon sagen
wirklich in mainstream also die frauen
kommen aus der mitte der katholischen
kirche die tragen seit jahren seit
jahrzehnten die haupt arbeit in den
gemeinden im ehrenamt bei der bei der
katechese für kinder wenn es um die
erstkommunionvorbereitung geht an vielen
anderen stellen in der kirchlichen
jugendarbeit wenn man sich anschaut den
vielen gemeinden die ministrantinnen die
altardiener eben sind mittlerweile fast
in der mehrzahl junge frauen mädchen
also von daher hier kommt ein protest
ein sturm wirklich kann man sagen in den
letzten jahren aus der mitte
woran liegt das dass frauen tatsächlich
so viel engagierter sind aber im
endeffekt dann doch nicht weiterkommen
ich weiß es nicht ich glaube über viele
jahre haben die frauen auch und auch
viele männer haben einfach die hoffnung
gehabt dass sich doch etwas verändert es
gab immer wieder auch kleine zeichen
dann gab es einen dialog prozess war in
der deutschen bischofskonferenz schon
2010 kurz nach dem die missbrauchsfälle
in dieser dimension in deutschland auch
bekannt geworden sind
da hat man viele hoffnungen daran
geknüpft auch in den früheren jahren
ältere erinnern sich in den 60er jahren
des letzten jahrhunderts gab es ein
großes reformkonzil in der katholischen
kirche alle bischöfe weltweit haben
veränderungen beschlossen da sind ganz
viele junge männer in die katholische
kirche in der katholischen kirche
priester geworden weil die sagten in
zehn jahren ist der pflichtzölibat weg
das ist dann alles nicht eingetreten und
von daher gab es dann schon auch immer
wieder große frust wellen aber immer
wieder auch diese kleinen hoffnung und
jetzt gibt es glaube ich seit einigen
jahren doch wirklich auch sage ich mal
eine phase wo man sagen muss wenn die
bischöfe jetzt nicht und der papst am
ende auch in rom wenn er jetzt nicht die
kurve kriegt dann könnte es schon
existenzbedrohlich werden für die
katholische kirche ein historiker aus
augsburg hat das vor wenigen tagen auch
schon gesagt wenn die katholische kirche
so weiter macht in 20 jahren wollen wir
mal sehen
zumindest hier in deutschland hier in
deutschland aber auch weltweit das ist
ja maria 2.0 es ist jetzt gerade am ende
angesprochen worden die sind ja auch
weltweit vernetzt das ist ja nicht nur
so dass es nur die frauen in deutschland
sind in vielen anderen ländern in den
usa aber auch in den ländern des südens
sind es viele frauen die sich engagieren
auch an vielen stellen ordensfrauen die
sagen leute wir wir wir tragen hier die
hauptlast der arbeit und wir wollen
jetzt mitreden
wir wollen jetzt in
entscheidungspositionen und von daher
ist es nicht irgendwo eine kleine gruppe
irgendwo in deutschland sondern das ist
ein phänomen dem begegnen sie überall
wenn sie rund um den globus schauen
es gibt doch jetzt aber diesen synodalen
weg das ist eins dieser katholischen
worte die man sonst nirgendwo anders
also quasi dieser versuch von den
geweihten priester an den bischöfen den
kardinälen zusammen mit den laien wie es
dann heißt den austausch zu treten und
zu gucken was man verändern kann ist das
nicht im grunde schon der reformprozess
den die aktivistinnen haben möchten also
die themen die da besprochen werden das
sind in der tat die themen die jetzt
auch bei dem thesenanschlag von maria
2.0 am vergangenen wochenende benannt
wurden aber es ist ja längst nicht klar
zu welchem ergebnis führt dieser
gesprächsprozess dieser dialog prozess
der da angestoßen wurde
und es gibt ganz ganz sag ich mal es
gibt kräfte gerade im konservativen
bereich die versuchen natürlich zu
verhindern dass es beim thema zugang von
frauen für die ämter das ist der
änderungen gibt dass es bei der frage
nach machtverteilung macht kontrolle
dass es da veränderungen gibt manche
versuchen dann die bande auch über rom
zu spielen also den vatikan weil auch
dort ich sag mal gibt es seit vielen
jahrzehnten durchaus viele vertreter die
sehr kritisch in richtung deutschland
gucken und freund wurde es angesprochen
die reformation
irgendwie hat man immer so ein bisschen
da im kopf bei einigen herren im vatikan
na ja was dann nördlich der alpen
passiert da muss man aufpassen die
wollen immer gleich sozusagen die kirche
völlig auf den kopf stellen und deshalb
ist man da sehr reserviert und viele
konservative kreise nutzen das dann auch
und versuchen über bande zu spielen in
dem man dann dinge nach rom berichtet
die sage ich mal sehr durch die eigene
brille betrachtet sind und rom dann
irgendwie denkt um gottes willen was
sind bild der synodale weg in anderthalb
jahren werden in deutschland frauen zu
priesterinnen geweiht das ist es nicht
was die bischöfe wollen in deutschland
und da sind glaube ich auch die laien
die frauen und männer ganz realistisch
und sagen dass wenn man nicht hinkriegen
am ende dieses dialog prozesses aber wir
möchten klar markieren das ist ein thema
das wollen wir auf weltkirchlicher ebene
besprochen haben und jetzt sollte der
papst mal gucken dass er mit seinen
geschöpfen und möglichst auch mit
beteiligung von laien auch über ein
solches thema offen spricht macht er das
denn nicht also ist der papst war fällig
wie die drei affen unterwegs ich halte
mir die ohren zu ich halte mir die augen
ziemlich wenn der papst doch natürlich
der papst nimmt das natürlich war und
als er als papst franziskus 2013 gewählt
wurde haben ja auch viele gesagt okay
jetzt wird die kirche sozusagen auf den
kopf gestellt dieser papst der wirt
reformen durchführen an an allen stellen
im bereich von gottes gab es sehr viele
hoffnungen beim thema frauen beim thema
zölibat beim thema homosexualität pubs
franziskus ist jetzt per se nicht der
große reformer aber ich glaube schon
dass er viele veränderungen der
katholischen kirche will und wollte aber
auch feststellen musste dass es ganz
massive gegen kräfte gibt die solche
dinge verhindern wollen sie haben es
vorhin auch angesprochen was ist wenn
die die unzufrieden sind aus der
katholischen kirche austreten wer bleibt
denn dann in der mehrzahl zurück und da
gibt es durchaus auch an eine
verschiebung von kräften innerhalb der
katholischen kirche
wenn man das weltweit betrachtet kann
das dann schon oder führt das dazu dass
der papst plötzlich merkt wenn er zum
beispiel über wieder veraltet
geschiedene diskutieren lässt
und da gerne veränderungen möchte mein
lieber freund da ist aber eine ganz
schön breite gegen front plötzlich
aufgebaut worden
er hat dann in der fußnote versucht da
so eine leichte öffnung in einem
offiziellen schreiben zu ermöglichen
das hat so ein bisschen die luft oder
den druck rausgenommen aus dem kessel
aber an vielen anderen stellen kommt er
nicht weiter und da kann so ein prozess
wie er jetzt in deutschland stattfindet
und auch in anderen ländern gibt es
ähnliche gesprächsprozess die jetzt
initiiert werden bischöfe zusammen mit
dem laien
da kann ich immer nur auch allen sagen
ihr müsst euch international vernetzen
damit auch deutlich wird das sind nicht
so einzelkämpfer in deutschland sondern
das ist weltweit eine große bewegung und
dann wird auch rom die augen davor nicht
mehr verschließen können ich habe ja
aber zb ein kommentar von oliver
reformen hört sich gut an aber niemals
für das ungetüm das 2000 jahre alt ist
auch in 2000 jahren gibt es die kirche
in dieser fassung ob ich so weit gehen
würde weiß ich jetzt nicht aber auch
meine frage jetzt also ist es nicht
ziemlich viel verlangt von einer 2000
jahre alten institution die ja wirklich
tradition von sehr weit weg noch mit
sich mit trägt dass die innerhalb von
wenigen jahrzehnten über bord
geschmissen
naja gut man muss sehen wenn man in die
geschichte schaut sieht man dass sich
die kirche immer auch wieder verändert
hat also ich glaube sonst hätte sie die
2000 jahre auch nicht überlebt aber
langsam oder sie hat sich ja sie hat
sich langsam verändert an anderen
stellen ging es durchaus auch ging es
durchaus auch mal schneller dass die
frage ist immer ein bisschen wie wie
groß oder wie stark wird auch in rom
signalisiert und wie dass diese
veränderung bewegungen dass die einfach
nicht nur einzelne gruppierungen sind
sondern dass man sich da wirklich
solidarisiert und gemeinsam auf den weg
macht ich glaube das ist ganz das ist
eine ganz entscheidende sache betroffene
im kontext des missbrauchsskandals haben
es meines erachtens ganz gut geschafft
sich international zu vernetzen und
versuchen immer wieder auch druck auf
den vatikan auszuüben damit dort einfach
dinge wirklich auch passieren und ich
glaube das kann durchaus auch ein
beispiel sein für andere
reformbewegungen dass man sagt wir
müssen uns solidarisieren wir müssen uns
zusammentun und klar die kirche denkt in
jahrhunderten aber die menschen und das
kann ich gut verstehen
die haben nicht diese zeit da geht es um
jahrzehnte
und ich kann mir schon vorstellen dass
da in den nächsten jahren durchaus
einige änderungen auf uns zukommen wenn
man jetzt zum beispiel mal schaut in
deutschland ein thema dass maria 2.0 und
der synodale weg ansprechend ist die
frage wie geht man mit zb
gleichgeschlechtlichen partnerschaften
um und da hört man jetzt in den letzten
monaten einen zwei jahren doch auch ganz
viele bischöfe die sagen ja zum beispiel
eine segnung für gleichgeschlechtliche
paare das können wir uns vorschreibt
richter nicht eine kirche auseinander
wenn man hier in deutschland dann solche
paare segnet während in anderen ländern
wo die katholische kirche auch stark
vertreten ist das immer noch als sünde
gilt und teilweise verboten ist das ist
ein großes problem seien wir vor dem der
papst eben immer steht im kontext der
familien synode diaz 2014/15 gab wollte
man durchaus das thema homosexualität
diskutieren und haben plötzlich
festgestellt für bischöfe die aus afrika
kommen selbst wenn sie wollten darüber
sehr offen diskutieren und vielleicht
auch
veränderungen wollten was ist wenn die
zurückkommen in der heimatland uganda
tansania auch einige bischöfe aus
osteuropäischen ländern
das ist in der tat das große problem
dass rom dann damit hat wenn man jetzt
beim thema wenn man bei dem thema
bleiben homosexualität wenn man da jetzt
veränderungen durchführt dann mag das
für deutschland mögen das und und
westeuropa wichtige schritte seien aber
die afrikanischen bischöfe kommen dann
stehen dann von einem riesenproblem wie
sie damit umgehen trott nichtsdestotrotz
wenn es und wenn man bei diesem thema
bleiben die der katholischen kirche
darum geht um die würde eines jeden
menschen dann muss sie sich eigentlich
auch gerade in diesen ländern bei diesem
thema dafür einsetzen dass menschen egal
ob frau mann diverse homosexuelle täter
sexuell bisexuell dass die auch ein
menschenwürdiges leben dort dafür aber
da geht es doch immer dann dieses
paradox dass einerseits dieses dogma
gibt so jeder mensch soll in seiner
einzigartigkeit wir von gott gemacht
wurde gewürdigt werden und geliebt
werden und dann aber homosexualität ist
eine strafe gerade zwischen männern ich
lese gerade wenn man auf meinen rechner
schalten live regie von event horizon
auf youtube die katholische kirche ist
natürlich nicht der emanzipierten rolle
der frau aufgeschlossen die bibel selbst
verbietet die gleichberechtigung von
mann und frau also es gibt dann doch
immer wieder diese worte in diesen sehr
alten buch an das ja alle glauben die
der katholischen kirche angehören die
widerspruch dazu stehen sich so zu
verhalten
gut man muss man natürlich sagen der
mainstream der katholischen kirche hat
eine wörtliche bibelauslegung seit sag
ich mal den 60er 70er jahren des letzten
jahrhunderts auf gottseidank überwunden
also man muss immer schauen in welchem
kontext sind denn aussagen in der bibel
entstanden sondern vorhin die zwölf
erwähne
die zwölf apostel mittlerweile haben wir
weltweit 4.500 bischöfe also da müsste
man ja auch sagen okay das sollten
eigentlich zwei zwölf apostel also
sprich 12 bischöfe jetzt einmal 400.000
das passt doch nicht zusammen und so
wird man an ganz vielen stellen dinge
finden wo man sagen muss man muss
historisch kritisch an diese aussagen
der bibel herangehen und dann verlieren
ganz viele aussagen sage ich mal gewicht
in der argumentation wenn es um das
thema homosexualität geht wenn es um das
thema frauen und gleichstellung der
frauen geht also da muss man dann schon
auch gucken und ehrlich mit diesem buch
umgehen und kann nicht sagen ich musste
es eins zu eins umsetzen wenn wir dann
ins alte testament gehen wo wir
möglicherweise einen rächenden und und
zürnen gott erleben wenn ich das dann
eins zu eins übersetzen dann dann wird
es ganz schwierig und deshalb muss muss
man sehr vorsichtig sein wenn man mit
bibelzitaten argumentiert und mit
verweisen auf die bibel weil man genau
hinschauen muss in welchem kontext sind
diese aussagen entstanden und wie muss
sich die heute und wie kann ich die
legitimerweise heute dann interpretieren
am 18 märz will das bistum köln das
zweite gutachten zu diesen
missbrauchsvorwürfen vorstellen
haben sie hoffnung dass sich dann
tatsächlich was ändert oder glauben sie
dass dieses gutachten tatsächlich sich
so unterscheidet von dem ersten was er
will kika de ki nicht veröffentlicht
sehen wollte
also bisher weiß ja niemand auch
kardinal welche nicht was in dem ersten
gutachten wirklich drin ist deshalb ist
es ja auch so ein bisschen seltsam dass
man in köln sagt wir können dieses
gutachten nicht veröffentlichen es ist
nicht nicht gerichtsfest
der kardinal hatte dazu gesagt dass wenn
dieses zweite gutachten veröffentlicht
ist dass man dann auch in das erste
einsicht erhalten wird und dann werden
die experten sagen müssen war dieser
ganze dieser ganze aufwand der da jetzt
betrieben wurde wirklich berechtigt oder
nicht
ich glaube man kann da schon auch
zweifel anmelden weil ein in allen
dieses dieser anwaltskanzlei hat ja nach
dem selben format eine studie einen ein
gutachten erstellt für das bistum aachen
das wurde veröffentlicht und und sage
ich mal alles war gut jetzt in bezug auf
die gerichts menschlichkeit und und die
verfahrens methoden die diese kanzlei
angewendet hat von daher
bin ich wirklich auch selbst sehr
gespannt was denn da so falsch sein soll
und was dieses zweite gutachten
aufarbeitet was man bisher vom 2
gutachter hört ist schon das dann noch
mal mehr fälle offenkundig werden wenn
dieses gutachten dann veröffentlicht
wird ob ich meine das entscheidende wird
dann sein ob die personen die benannt
werden sei es jetzt im ersten oder im
zweiten ob die wirklich persönliche
konsequenzen ziehen und das ist das was
die betroffenen jetzt in dieser phase in
der wir jetzt sind in bezug auf die
aufarbeitung des sexuellen missbrauchs
der sexualisierten gewalt was die
betroffenen erwarten dass jetzt endlich
personen handelnde personen
verantwortung übernehmen und zum einen
was vorhin angeklungen ist auch noch mal
wirklich dann sagen ich habe hier fehler
gemacht ich bitte um entschuldigung aber
dass sie dann auch die konsequenzen
ziehen und bischof bätzing der
vorsitzende der bischofskonferenz hat ja
heute mittag nicht ausgeschlossen in der
pressekonferenz dass es dann auch zu
rücktritten von bischöfen kommen kann
und also wenn das nicht passiert dann
glaube ich ist offenkundig dass man
nicht will da noch mal ne kurze frage
gab es mittlerweile eigentlich mal
priester die verurteilt worden von
weltlichen gerichten wegen dieser
missbrauchsvorwürfe ja die gab es es gab
priester die sowohl von weltlichen als
auch von kirchlichen gerichten
verurteilt wurden es gibt auch die
situation wo die fälle vor weltlichen
gerichten nicht mehr verhandelt werden
können weil sie verjährt sind aber dann
doch noch vor kirchlichen gerichten
verhandelt werden und dann die
entsprechenden konsequenzen zu tragen
sind das geht dann bis dahin dass die
priester aus dem priester aus dem
klerikerstand entlassen werden also das
gab es auf beiden seiten in vielen
fällen aber stehen in einem verhältnis
zu der masse darf der vorwürfe oder der
verdächtigen
das ist ganz schwer zu sagen weil es
bisher darüber keine statistischen
angaben gibt wie viele sind es denn
jetzt wirklich und auch nicht alle fälle
die verstaatlichen vor staatlichen
gerichten zur anzeige und dann zur
verurteilung kommen dann in den medien
präsent sind und irgendwie da sind muss
ich ganz ehrlich sagen das wäre
vielleicht mal das müsste man
recherchieren
ich glaube dass die zahl eher gering ist
im verhältnis zu der zahl derer die die
beschuldigt werden
aber da gibt es kann also mir ist bisher
keine keine stabile datenlage bekannt
dazu aber da sehen wir ja schon wie
schwierig das thema sie zu fassen
am 18 märz wird also das zweite
gutachten geben das erste gutachten soll
auch teilweise veröffentlicht werden den
journalisten ich gehe davon aus dass sie
das nicht auch angucken dürfen dann sind
wir gespannt was sie davon zu berichten
haben für heute sage ich aber vielen
dank herr einfacher dass die bei uns
waren
vielen dank an euch dass ihr zugeguckt
habt dass ihr fragen gestellt hat munter
kommentiert habt es ist ein schwieriges
thema die katholische kirche wird sich
bewegen müssen das ist glaube ich
konsens jetzt hier gewesen in diesem
gespräch wir sind nun gespannt in welche
richtung und daher sage ich wir heute
vielen dank und bis bald